I'm here with actor and director Diego
Luna who is premiering his short film
Nana Diego thank you so much for being
with us first just tell me why did you
decide to do a short piece about a woman
who works as a nanny I was raised by not
one but by many nannies my mother died
when I was 2 so I remember being always
around women that came from places I
didn't know existed that helped me find
out that the world was much more complex
than what I thought and that raised me
and and helped me to be Who I am I guess
it was a different difficult challenge
you know what what the foundation and
the Institute were we're asking us to do
you know and I thought of well how to
talk about something very personal I
guess what worlds did the women who took
care of you
clue you in to I wasn't exposed I guess
to to the amount of an equality and
poverty that my country has I wasn't
exposed to the diversity the culture of
diversity that also the country I mean
the in the country there is more than oh
it's just there's almost 300 different
languages you know there is like all
these communities that still live as
they did hundreds of years ago and and I
was you know the rat of the city
thinking that was it you know that was
Mexico New Mexico
I guess the hope is why I did this film
you know I I don't know if my father was
are not aware of all of these we're
talking about but I am you know and and
that changed the perspective I see the
world from and if we if one day we want
to change this world is because yeah we
acknowledge what's around us we
acknowledge that we are part of what's
around us and that and that we have a
responsibility of just being here means
there is a responsibility you know we
have to be informed we have to we we
have to care you know and we have to
fight indifference basically well thank
you so much for talking with us thank
you
giggling ah such a pleasure my pleasure
enjoy Sundance I will
you